hello everyone and welcome to a very
important game for the chess history for
the chess world and for us the chess
players it's a game from 1973 a lottery
Open Championship I was played in
Daugavpils the second-largest city after
riga between russian international
master Vladimir kurasov and Rasheeda
nish Medina and at the time this game
was played it was a rush it was already
struggling which is with his illness and
I don't know if he was already diagnosed
with cancer but but if not very soon so
definitely you know it did take a huge
toll on him as he couldn't even finish
this tournament he had to leave the
tournament without without finishing it
so we're gonna come back to that for a
bit after we check out this game it's a
one of one of Finnish Medine of last
great victories and one of the one of
the last games he ever played so kurasov
opens with an eye to f3 the reti opening
we have Knight to f6 c4 c5 and the d4
the is the English opening the
symmetrical variation we have Punk after
Sun d4 Knight captures on d4 and now II
6 nice to see 3 Bishop to b4 attacking
pinning the knight but also threatening
to capture in the double of white C
points and here we have Knights the b5
kurasov now prevents the doubling of the
pawns and here of course you could go
nice to d6 next move is like it doesn't
do anything about this you could capture
here and then white will capture back
which will basically give you nothing
you've given up the bishop repair
without causing any damage and the one
otherwise a measure Medina could
continue this is by playing d5 if
somebody to be a very nice sharp line
but a very forcing light which doesn't
give anything
instead he castles here and here we have
Bishop to f4 going after that d6 square
an edge matino now goes for d5 we have a
three attacking the bishop and now
Bishop captures on c3 Knight captures on
c3 and now d4 forcing the knight to
react to this d4 push and also keeping
the king in the center not allowing
not allowing this III move I was a nice
to be five and now a six a very
interesting idea that allows anonymity
enough to create something we have a
knight to c7 attacking the rook rook
comes back to a7 and now you kind of do
have to do something about this Knight
and c7 here Knight the beef I was played
which is a small in accuracy Knight to
d5 would have been better with the same
idea if pawn captures then Bishop
captures here rue goes back goes back
and everything is fine so this is
basically the idea kurasov had when he
played a nice the b5 but unfortunately
here it's not so great here in this
Medina played a capture some b5 Bishop
captures RB 8 and here probably Carazo
was expecting locate and Bishop back to
e5 but there's Medina of felt that there
was more to the position that you know
the the opportunity has presented itself
to create something and you know news
Medina does not pass on an opportunity
like this
so instead be captures on c4 he gives up
the rock and a7 to grab the give up the
exchange after Queen to a5 check and ok
you kind of do have to go for this
Bishop captures on a7 Queen to a5 check
only move is to block with the Queen we
have Queen to d2 and now Queen captures
on a 7 so ok nazar Medina is down the
exchange but these two points are very
powerful the queen is also now guarding
d4 from a7 and also the double the White
King is still in the center so you do
have to do something about this very
quickly
III was played immediately trying to get
that Bishop into the game but of course
there's Medina doesn't allow it d3 and
now you don't really have a lot of
options here your only option here to
maybe even try to save this game is
Bishop captures rook to d8 it doesn't
work because of Bishop captures on h7
capturing the rook what after captures
captures
ok you you now have a rook against a
bishop and the night but maybe with with
two points on the Queen side you could
you could hope for something but in the
game g3 was played and now white is out
of options here and there's Medina
immediately goes for the night 9 3 4
attacking the Queen we have Quinta
before and now comes D to with check
King Ito and now comes Queen to a6
threatening c3 with a discovered to
check King to f3
now comes Queen to c6 simply removing
the Queen also no threatening
discoveries King has to go back to e2
and now comes Queen to d5 keeping an eye
on everything and white really doesn't
have a useful move here rook to d1
stopping that point from being pushed
forward but now comes a five again a
very nice idea the bishop is ready to
jump to g4 we have h3 stopping that and
now comes b6 b6 now you see that the
bishop can also come into the game via
Bishop to e6 and then c3 will yet again
be a terrible threat rock to g1 now if
the knight moves at least the rookin
what we attacked by the Queen we have c3
now you do have to play something rush
up to a 6 is coming with check and
there's really nothing to play here we
have pawn captures on c3 there really
was no better move Knight captures on c3
with check and it was in this position
unmoved 25 that Russian international
master Vladimir Tarasov resigned the
game he resigned because there is
nothing more to do here it's a it's a
fourth line after the knight is captured
the the King has nowhere to go
the point is guarding he won Queen is
guarding f3 also d3 you do have to
capture the night and then Bishop to a6
is deadly
the King has nowhere to go you have to
give up the Queen after Queen captures
it's it's a nice King walk but it
doesn't end well for her for white
Russia b7 check King moves Queen to g6
check King has to move Queen h6 check
King moves and now of course
f5 finishes the game nicely wood with a
wood a wonderful checkmate so yeah
that's the game from 1973 watching an
Open Championship like Mikasa versus a
Rashid Nash Medina and it's like tal
said in the quote above the board as you
can see I am both said and pleased that
in his last tournament Rashid gabbatha
which came to my home in Latvia he did
not take first place but the price for
beauty is all
he took with him players died
tournaments are forgotten but the works
of great artists are left behind them to
live on forever so Rasheed did not
finish this tournament but he did win
shared third and fourth place in this
tournament without in playing all games
and this game did win him the brilliancy
prize so that's you know that's as tall
says it's it's always the same
regardless of who wins the tournament
isn't the price for beauty always goes
to Rashid about tuition years may be
enough so yeah that was the game I do
hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
all for watching and I will see you
tomorrow with another Russian is Medina
game thank you all and don't forget to
mention Russia to all your friends and
show him a couple of games by him season